the Joe Rogan experience some dudes are
just so frugal I always find that so
funny cuz I'm such a slob but that's how
we were we started in Boston oh you were
driving a [ __ ] so was it a celica GT
or something it was a Mitsubishi Starion
it's like a little sporty layer yeah
yeah and you were leasing it and I was
like who the [ __ ] leases a new car when
they've been doing comedy for two years
and I had a [ __ ] I had an 84
Volkswagen Rabbit and I just remember
you you had a [ __ ] nice where you had
a jacked-up stereo system in it and I
remember you got it got [ __ ]
repossessed no that was a different car
that was the Dodge Daytona Shelby I got
rid of the one and then I got the second
one and you didn't give a [ __ ] oh you
went to the you went to the impound lot
and you jumped the fence to get the
radio I had a stereo I put in it I
installed the stereo I jumped the fence
and pulled the [ __ ] stereo out of the
Daytona because I knew I wasn't gonna be
able to pay for that [ __ ] car anymore
it was actually that was the first year
of comedy that was my first year
actually it got that while I was still
teaching and I was still I taught I was
teaching at Boston University I was
teaching Taekwondo there I was teaching
at this school that I was running in
Revere and I was delivering newspapers
so I was making a little bit of money
and I was really stupid and when I found
out that I could get a car like a
brand-new Dodge Daytona Shelby in 1988
or 1989 and I could I could lease it
they would lease it to me yeah what I
was like perfect let's do it but then
somewhere along the line I had decided I
was really gonna dedicate myself to
stand up I was like I am I'm half-assing
this and somebody told me that one of
the guys that I was doing open mic
nights they said you know you were
really funny like six months ago that
big goes but it seems like you've fallen
off a little and he said it to me and I
didn't even respond I remember like [ __ ]
he's right yeah he's right he's right
I'm half-assing it and then that night I
was like [ __ ] this I'm quitting
everything so I decided was gonna quit
teaching I quit teaching at BU I quit
teaching at high school I shut my school
down
I got it I got to be a comic 100% and
then I had no money so you just said
live off whatever I make I was trying to
get odd jobs during the day yeah but I
couldn't have anything that I was
dedicated to all right and when I was
teaching I was very dedicated to
teaching it meant a lot to me like
martial arts meant a lot to me so
technique means a lot to me so when I
was teaching people it's very specific
it meant a lot yeah and I would teach
people on a bring them to tournaments
and you know I raised kids from like
white belt all the way up to like blue
belt and brought him to tournaments and
it was exciting was really fun it meant
a lot to me though it meant enough to me
that I was not gonna half-ass it I was
like I'm not gonna I'm not gonna have
teach these people because when I was
teaching I was very serious about it
meant a lot so I was like I'm not
I got a I'm out I'm not go once I have a
thing I'm like that's the thing all
these other things just get in the way
of the thing just eliminate those and so
that's what I did and then they took my
[ __ ] car but I got the stereo back I
remember cuz I was I was living with
your girlfriend and you were coming over
every night [ __ ] you'd come from like
cappuccinos the restaurant around the
corner with [ __ ] takeout like nice
meals I was eating [ __ ] ramen noodles
I spent every penny I spent everything
in put anything away ever come from
Blockbuster with [ __ ] five movies
under your arm yeah you were living with
my girlfriend and another dude yeah a
guy named Mike Mike coconut who's a
great guy he was a great dude he who's
the first guy ever met hell out of
Bowflex oh no [ __ ] yeah he was the first
guy I met who was growing marijuana in
his closet
oh [ __ ] lights that's dangerous in
Boston in the 80s right you go to jail
jail he groped he that was some skunk
weed we see really smoking that skunk
weed you could go to jail Joe yeah
[Applause]